britney spears is making moves to have
her father permanently removed as her
conservator
less than two weeks ago we pledged
that after 13 years of the status quo
my firm and i would move aggressively
and expeditiously to file a petition to
suspend
and remove james p spears
it is now a matter of public record
and i announced to judge penny this
afternoon
that we have done so in less than two
weeks
we look forward to litigating the matter
in court following brittany's
bombshell testimony last month the
singer has filed new documents naming
who
she wants to replace her dad jamie in
new court documents obtained by e.t on
monday
we now know who the singer wishes to
take his place
we really kind of butt heads in that
department the docs revealed britney's
attorneys have requested
cpa jason rubin be named as the new
conservator
previously jamie spears was in charge of
britney's estate
and her attorneys have asked that
authority to be transferred to rubin
i'm very keen on freedom i love freedom
i love independence
so who is jason rubin according to his
website
reuben has been a practicing forensic
accountant
since the early 90s and has experience
with complex
civil litigation and trust portfolios
the new filing questions jamie's
handling of brittany's estate
referencing quote the evident
dissipation of ms spears's fortune
which mr spheres has effectively
controlled since 2008.
earlier this year et learned that
jamie's legal team charged nearly 900
thousand dollars for five months of work
all of which is paid through brittany's
estate i think
my daughter has had more than her share
of stress
the 127 page document also features a
declaration from brittany's mom
lynn where she calls her ex-husband
jamie's control over their daughter
quote terrifying and compared it to
quote
living in custody over on the home front
sister jamie lynn spears is refuting
rumors
that brittany bought her a condo she's
like she's 10 years younger than me but
she's like so stubborn
and she's like so headstrong on monday
jamie lynn took to instagram and wrote
quote
i don't own a condo and i can assure you
that no one has ever bought me
a place at the beach because i prefer my
beach vacations at the ritz
anyways she added quote y'all need to
stop
reaching while jamie lynn denied owning
a condo
she has previously referenced having a
condo
in 2015 jamie lynn replied to a fan's
question on twitter
about her favorite vacation spot she
wrote quote
we have a condo in destin florida and
it's the best getaway
and in 2016 jamie lynn told cmt
news she felt pretty blessed to have the
condo
the new developments follow the free
britney movement gaining a
big supporter over the weekend on sunday
brittany's
longtime agent and friend kade hudson
spoke out against her conservatorship
sharing this
lengthy message to instagram kade wrote
in part
quote this is a violation of someone's
basic human
rights elsewhere in the post kate
explained why he hasn't spoken out until
now
cade said quote i've kept my mouth shut
out of the fear
of losing my job while he doesn't
identify the individual
kate alleges someone who repeatedly
threatened his career
only referring to the person as quote
the man we all know who
and adding quote i won't even dignify
mentioning his name in the comments
cade's message received plenty of
celebrity support
sarah jessica parker andy cohen and
paris hilton
just to name a few and she's just
so sweet and down to earth and really an
amazing woman and i'm just
so proud of her kade also took a moment
to praise britney's new attorney
matthew rosengart calling him quote the
best of the best
and someone who knows the work has just
begun